memento to a really nice apartment right
you know it's a decent place but he's
surrounded by rats and what painted yeah
you gotta hear this this is such a it's
a nightmare right now how do you sleep
through this uh you can't I mean [ __ ] is
already bad enough with all his Corona
stuff going on and we have this awful
landlord and I don't know like if he has
Kovac and he's dead or something but he
doesn't respond to our calls anymore
like he's completely m.i.a it's crazy we
open the window of some on street level
and they're sitting on the
air-conditioning unit
oh my god how big are they they the size
of like a cat oh yeah this is the noise
he hears next to his head when he's
trying to sleep rats scratching through
the walls listen to this
[Music]
yeah you know what my man I bet you if
you don't pay your rent
you'll hear from your [ __ ] landlord
yeah multiple people told me just stop
paying rent right until the anti : can I
get arrested for that can I get in
trouble
here's Dorothy who wants her coming once
a comment on that [ __ ] one that I don't
know what neighborhood you live in but
I've been in housing court most of my
life if you have lat your building can
do a red strike and what you should
immediately do when you get done with
the show is called HPD I have a direct
number to them do not pay your rent hold
it in escrow I don't know what
neighborhood you in I'm in the East
Village I get everything delivered
laundry wine food I'm not stepping
outside right now that's smart such a
tiny apartment you've got to get out and
get some kind of fresh air what do you
have roof access
no I like Dorothy like that don't let
you go onto the roof to the alarm that's
what I did it's survival of the fittest
in this town right there dear get
upstairs it's a beautiful day
go watch the [ __ ] airplanes flying
over get a little hibachi barbecue take
the bull by the horns get it together
be particular OCD and paranoia is your
friend right now also being a little a
monster against your landlord that's
come bad your biggest fan is on the
phone this is a woman named Rose she
says she is Dorothy's biggest fan
listen yes this chick knows what she's
talking about she's [ __ ] right
but mess take that [ __ ] landlord put
him in a [ __ ] show call till he shits
his head Wow Rose you know what's going
on here and you'll get up on that roof
you know wait for anyone get you on the
roof you're breaking you go up and if
they give you [ __ ] like the building on
fire [ __ ] up I wouldn't do anything that
illegal too
no no as a fitted well like you I don't
trust these broads
I'll break your ass okay you know all
right thank you that is Rose who is
Dorothy
Dorothy's biggest fan
you